كان تايجر وودز يقود سيارته أسفل التل على
الجانب الآخر من الطريق ،
فقد السيطرة بطريقة ما عبرت متوسط
هذا الرصيف ثم
لب عمدة المقاطعة ، وقال إن
انقلب عد
مرات في تلك السيارة الرياضية متعددة الاستخدامات من خلال كل
ذه الشجيرات وانظر إلى أي مد
سافر جم
عًا  الطريق هنا يتدحرج اصطدم بشجرة
ثم هبطت سيارته إلى الأسفل
هنا الآن
قال النائب الأول في المشهد الشاب
يدعى كارلوس غونزاليس
إنه يعتقد أن تايجر وودز
كان محظوظًا للخروج من هذا على قيد الحياة
وبصراحة أتفق مع  إنه ما زلت
أسير حيث كانت سيارته تتدحرج
وهذا
هو المكان الذي انتهى فيه الأمر بسيارة تايجر وودز الآن على
ما يبدو أنه كان هادئًا ، لكن
نائب غونزاليس قال ربما كان ذلك عبارة عن
كسور مركبة في ساقيه واعيًا
عند وصول خدمات الطوارئ